one of the things I like to talk about a
lot at our company is we kind of have
this motto around our work style which
is high expectations High trust High
accountability and so we look to bring
in people who can fit this this model
and what I mean by this is high
expectations we set the bar really high
uh High trust as we we will not
micromanage we will allow our folks to
um you know we will equip them to do
whatever they need to do with the tools
and resources they need to be successful
but we'll let them go figure out how to
Go Achieve that goal if we didn't hit
our goal why and and what can we do
better next time and that process I
think is really unique for organizations
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
with Will Robinson the CEO at impacture
a high growth SAS platform that helps
Banks automatically extract important
information from documents launched 20
years ago in Dallas Texas and capture
helps companies such as Wells Fargo
Frost Bank and truest save time and
money by using machine learning to
process large amounts of data since
joining the fast growing company in 2019
will has assembled a strong team of
individuals that shares his passion for
fintech and AI banking ensuring
sustainable growth achieving Innovative
excellence and tripling revenue he leads
in capture with an emphasis and passion
for company culture and setting a high
standard of Excellence for a team that
is constantly learning and excelling
their user-friendly automation empowers
Banks to save valuable time and reduce
compliance Risk by processing documents
efficiently and accurately in an easily
accessible format instead of getting
bogged down with quarterly compliance
and regular audits they can put a
greater focus on delivering an
exceptional customer experience and
boosting satisfaction best of all no
technical expertise is required to
utilize and reap the benefits of the in
capture platform thanks to the power of
sophisticated machine learning AI
[Music]
thank you very very much for joining me
I'm really excited to talk to you about
fintech AI Banking and capture what
you're doing today and I think it's
we're definitely going to have a lot of
fun over these 20 minutes so again thank
you first for being here and tell me a
little bit about you know what do you
really care about now what really you
know moves the needle for you
yeah for me personally uh I really love
building High performing teams and being
part of that it's really fun to get a
big group of people together who are out
to set some pretty ambitious goals and
then figure out a way to go get it done
and so
um you know a lot of times in my role
there's a lot of talk about hitting
certain Revenue targets or uh you know
being in a certain competitive
positioning but really for me what it
comes down to is how do we get a big
group of people together uh to Rally
around the same vision the same goal and
then run through walls to make it happen
because as you know and as many of these
listeners know building a company is is
hard and it takes a lot of work and it
takes some luck and there are days that
more things seem to go wrong than right
but having the right team
um and having people kind of achieve
something greater than they think they
can do on their own is really what gets
me motivated I love it wonderful well
tell me a little bit about
um your entrance with fintech and AI
banking what where where did that start
what does that even mean for you
yeah it's kind of funny I started uh
actually I started in banking I was a I
was a finance econ grad coming out of
out of college and
um went and worked
um on Wall Street right out of school
and so really got exposed to the uh
Financial Community
uh kind of pretty quickly uh right out
of school and it started off as a as an
investment banker and and worked after
that worked for a big private Equity
Firm that invested in software companies
and uh that's where I fell in love with
the software space I felt like as a
young person for the rest of my career
software would be disrupting the world
and
um you know I'm really fortunate to be
here to capture where uh you know we're
building great software to help help
financial institutions
um streamline streamline their back
office operations so that's um that was
my kind of Entry to it I'm not a uh I'm
not a uh you know a technical founder or
leader I've got great folks who do that
um I come at this more from kind of
being in the industry and and being more
on the um kind of the operator side of
it so
it definitely sounds like it so coming
from within the industry
um how does software meet
um the Banking and Financial industry
you know from a very you know
um
you know grounded perspective how no
tangibly how how is it how how do you
identify the different potential
possibilities and and what did you
identify with and capture that led to
your conviction that what you're doing
now is really solving a a significant
need for the banking industry
yeah Michael I think you hit it on the
head you have to start with a problem
um and if you can't find uh if you can't
find a clear problem that's a big
problem to solve uh I think you're
always going to struggle with product
Market fit and so for us that problem is
around
um within Banks they are collecting a
lot of paperwork across across a lot of
different workflows in a lot of
different departments and there's a lot
of data trapped in those documents that
is critical for them to open a new
checking account or uh process a loan or
report
data to the proper regulatory
authorities and um and and every day
banks are struggling to handle all the
incoming documents and so where in
capture sits is we have machine learning
that can make it easy to read the
documents and we can we can identify the
important data within the documents and
extract it automatically so that people
don't have to sit there and manually
enter data or demand manual steer and
compare
across all these different workflows so
it's a it's a really really powerful
platform it solves a lot of different
pain points and I think if anything
we've had to be disciplined although we
when we walk up and we talk to a
prospective uh banking customer there's
like 30 40 different things we can do
for them so really nailing
um what the problem is most important to
them
and so so you know doing these types of
this type of work in AI how how how is
this specialized versus generalized
because this idea of extracting
information from documents you know
that's relevant for pretty much every
industry how do you how do you now think
through and I know that you're you're
coming
um
from from within the industry but how do
you see the intersection of AI
specialized AI within you know this use
case is that very even relevant to think
about it as Specialized or is this just
a general technology that can be
applicable to any industry
yes funny the the technology itself can
apply to any industry across any
workflow and so
um you know even though we're focused
you know one on you know right now our
go to market is 100 on financial
institutions we do have non-banking
customers we've got some government
agencies that work with us uh we've had
insurance we have some Fortune 500
customers that use our platform and so
really you can apply it anywhere and I
think for us given we're you know we're
we're smaller we're 60 employees
um you know we really have to be focused
on what vertical do we want to go attack
and my mindset is always let's go apply
to very specific problem kind of go inch
wide and Mild deep and let's go dominate
so for us you know financial
institutions we're specialized in the
sense that we know these processes
really really well we know what sort of
data these banks are looking for uh
we've got some pre-configured Solutions
on top of our platform that solve the
most common uh you know pain points
around certain document types and
certain data that these banks are trying
to collect so we think we could provide
a solution stand up our platform really
really quickly for these Banks relative
to them just buying kind of some general
purpose AI platform and then trying to
tailor it to their use case so that's
how we that's how we land and you know
we have a lot of uh there are a lot of
other players doing what we do for
different Industries and when you look
at our underlying technology it's
probably
um pretty similar but uh the way we win
is you know we've proven we can do it in
this space and we know we know these
workflows really really well
and incredible so and from my
understanding from what you're saying
um is the specialization
technological or business oriented in
terms of
um you know the way that you perceive
your own work so inch wide mile deep is
that technologically or from a sort of
go to market product business approach
yeah it's probably more on the business
product side it's less technical the the
technical there are some things unique
things we do technically that that work
well for this space but these they could
also be applied to in you know insurance
or health care so uh I think the winners
are going to be the in our space that
are using AI to go solve problems I
think the winners are the ones that can
really understand their their customers
pain point and have kind of
off-the-shelf solutions that can be
deployed very very quickly uh to go get
the value out of that AI versus building
something from scratch yeah no that that
makes a lot of sense and so where are
you now with uh within capture
yeah so we're about 60 employees uh
we've got
um
you know uh I think we're approaching 40
to 50 customers on our platform we've
got some of the biggest banks in the
world like uh truest and U.S bank and
Wells Fargo
um we've got some really nice Regional
sized banks that are in a handful of
states and then we're actually starting
to work more and more with smaller uh
Community Banks
um if you think about AI of course the
big banks have a lot of budget and
resources available to them but smaller
banks have historically never been uh
served by any sort of vendor that is
that is providing um AI so we feel like
there's a lot of opportunity there uh
there's some unique things about the
banking industry that
um require them to you know uh collect
information via documentation and check
it and double check it and store it
properly that we feel like we can take
advantage of so
um it's we've been in a a period of
rapid growth over the last two to three
years and um you know really excited
about what the next couple years have
for us
phenomenal and if you had to
or speculate a little bit as to the how
how this industry is moving forward and
some of the big opportunities
um that are that are going to to show
here how are you perceiving it you know
from your perspective
yeah so I think for the industry broadly
like in terms of AI uh I think there's a
ton of use cases before it and Banks
are uh
rightly so concerned about kind of
startup fintech lenders or or
alternative financial institutions that
are taking a lot of market share around
customer deposits or loan loan volumes
and so traditional banks are saying hey
look we're about you know we're we feel
like we're getting disrupted
um but at the same time we have this 100
year old brand we have a really really
uh core stable of of customers and we
feel like we you know we serve our
communities really well
so how do we stay relevant and I think
this is where introducing automation
um and AI can really help these Banks
maintain their competitive position
um and you know candidly just like any
other industry banks are facing the same
issues it's hard to find and hire really
good people
um and when you have great folks you
want to equip them with all the tools
they need to be highly successful in
their role and this is something AI is a
very practical you know believe it or
not there's a the type of AI that we do
is very practical it can be deployed
without a lot of expertise and so we
feel like there's going to be continued
adoption of automation Technologies over
the next several years and we think it's
going to allow Banks to stay very
competitive against some of these up
Stars
so going back to a building High
performing teams and that's a topic I'm
also personally very curious about and
so share with me a little about
your some of your you know personal
stories and understandings as to how to
what it takes to build a high performing
team what and what does that even mean
how do you even measure uh whether a
team is high performing or not
yeah that's a great question so I think
that's I think that's a good start is
you have to measure it and so whenever
you define
um high performance ads whether that's
hitting certain financial goals or
releasing product in a certain time or
trying to be the first innovator in a
new space to figure something out I
think setting really really clear goals
is important because if people don't
know what their what their goals are
it's gonna be hard for them to
understand if they're being successful
and candidly I'm a believer that setting
really aggressive goals and stretch
goals actually allows people to push
themselves a little bit further than
they otherwise would have and so one of
the things that we do and one of the
things I like to talk about a lot at our
company is we kind of have this motto
around our work style which is high
expectations High trust High
accountability and so we look to bring
in people who can fit this this model
and what I mean by this is high
expectations we set the bar really high
high try trust is we we will not
micromanage we will allow our folks to
um
you know we will quit them to do
whatever they need to do with the tools
and resources they need to be successful
but we'll let them go figure out how to
Go Achieve that goal and then the
accountability piece is more about
circling back on the end and saying okay
if we if we didn't hit our goal why and
and what can we do better next time in
that process I think is really unique
for organizations a lot of places don't
um like the sugarcoat feedback or they
don't like to get together and talk
about the hard problems that they have
excuse me and I think this is something
we've done really well where we can get
together and it's again it goes back to
that high trust we can come together we
know everybody's a high performer and we
can say look where did we fall short
what do we learn from it and what can we
do differently next time and that's
really in a spirit of love and
collaboration
um and respecting the other people
versus a place where it's uh you know
derogatory or to meeting so that's a
little bit of kind of the mindset that
we've taken here to capture
um and it you know there are certain
people who thrive in that but there are
certain people who don't who don't do
well they they they need to be
shepherded a little bit more directly
um they want kind of more incremental
feedback and um you know we've really
tried to find people that can come in
and say hey I really want to go do
something special and please give me
room to run
um we love we love those folks
do have some you know some suggestions
or tips for for managers who want to you
know consider whether you know how they
can improve on on their team and how and
what different ways they can evaluate
whether their team inside performing or
who are the most really the exceptional
people that they want to double down on
or the ones who are perhaps not helping
the team run forward what's from from
your own you know leadership background
how how do you think through those
I think there's a couple ways I mean
there's a lot of the kind of cliche
things
um
around
you know how people communicate or you
know how they how they interact with
with other team members I think one
thing we look for is
like like little things I look for to
see if someone's a high performer
you know how engaged are they with with
the team around them and actually High
performers are more engaged with the
people around them because they are they
are trying to achieve something that
they know they can only do with their
team and so they're constantly pinging
people bringing people into
conversations
um really trying to drive something
forward in a collective manner versus uh
kind of the Lone Wolf mentality where
people kind of go off in the corner and
say I'm gonna do this all figure this
all by myself that's that's usually a
red flag if someone's not really
engaging in your team so you know that's
a that that's a big one for us
um you know people who people are
willing to kind of raise their hand and
ask for help is actually a great sign
for a high performer it means that
they're aware of their of their
limitations and uh then they're not in
their self-confident enough to to raise
their hand and say hey I need some help
I can't figure this out or I'm stuck or
I don't feel like I'm doing a good job
here and uh so there's a couple things
that we look for things we really try to
encourage and promote uh at our company
because it it allows I think it allows
people to kind of take a deep breath and
be like all right this is not a high
pressure weather room
operation this place is a place where
people really are here to support me and
collaborate
um but there is an expectation that I
you know I do my job and I do it well
and and what do you personally and get
the most fulfillment from you know as a
as a leader where does your own
enjoyment and fulfillment comes because
like I gather that it's you know
partially a very you know definitely
curious about the problem space and
excited about the the solutions you're
bringing to the market but it also
sounds very much a team oriented
approach where where is your own joy and
excitement coming from
yeah I think it's I think it's kind of
what I talked about at the beginning
around uh I like seeing my people
succeed it's really fun you know and
it's really fun to see we have a lot of
um we're Junior Folks at our company who
are just starting out their professional
careers and it's really fun to see them
grow and mature to see them you know um
maybe achieve things or handle
situations that they otherwise who
wouldn't think they could and and you
know whether it's putting you know
putting a person in front of a customer
or having them solve a a difficult
problem in an implementation or having a
young sales guy kind of Step Up And Take
on you know some bigger accounts bigger
opportunities I take a lot of Joy when
um people personally can kind of go
achieve their professional dreams
um and and by doing so not only are they
being successful with their allowing
people around them to be successful so
so that's the fun part for me yeah that
you know the X's and O's around
product Market fit and competitive
differentiation and pricing strategies
um and you know marketing tactics I do
enjoy that but the people side of it is
the most fun when when you really see
people
um kind of come alive professionally and
grow very quickly yeah no 100 and I
think that it's you know growth is
significantly the you know that the most
important the most important pillar here
and
going back a little bit to to wrap up
the conversation around you know and
capture an AI and banking you know as
you sort of look at the market and you
understand the way that your technology
is being able to get integrated into
these different systems
you know as a leader you know what what
is sort of your greater Vision so you
mentioned you know your different
vertical focuses different impacts on
different Industries you're coming from
your own background how do you envision
the vision front capture in the market
yeah you know I think our goal is to
become kind of the preeminent
um
Nei provider for financial institutions
in our space you know the AI that we
provide is around processing documents
and extracting data so you know we're
not going to sit here and try to go
invent the next coolest chat mod
um for for banks to engage with their
borrowers that's that's not the type of
AI we do but I think for our space uh we
want to you know there's five thousand
Banks out there and wow we have 40 of
them
um so so there's a lot of opportunity
and we've got a great track record of
doing this
um and we provide a lot of value to the
to the customers and Banks who work with
us today and so you know I want us to be
kind of known as the the premier player
here and candidly you know once we do
that uh there's an opportunity to move
move into other Industries as we talked
about earlier so that's kind of the big
vision for for what we're trying to do
and uh you know it takes it's not just
me we've got a great team here that
that's going to make it happen
wonderful well hey well I'm really
excited to continue sharing from the
side thank you very much for your time
and for the energy and for doing this I
really really appreciate it wishing you
best of luck within capture and I'm
excited to share this story so thank you
awesome thanks Michael for having me I
appreciate it thank you
[Music]